[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum very special guest
today but before we talk about the
guests and you get to listen to them I
hope you'll uh just subscribe if you
like this interview uh subscribe to this
little podcast meet me happy make the
podcast happy so we can keep doing this
for all you amazing people out there and
uh the handles are at insidee podcast on
Facebook and Instagram at inside epod on
the Twitter uh we have inside of you
online store we have a bunch of great
merch and tumblers got new tumblers
coming in we got Smallville stuff lexmus
scripts tons of great stuff check out
the inside of you online store I'll be
doing cons I'm on the Cameo blarity blar
sunspin.com is the band name we will be
playing June 24th 5 PM Pacific Standard
Time get tickets come see us it's fun
there's prizes you know we're going to
give a random
a random person who comes to the concert
it's it's virtual you go to stageit.com
or sunspin.com you type in sunspin but
uh we're gonna give them a zoom a few
minutes Zoom for free a random
at the stage Rob doesn't even know about
this Rob is my guitarist uh so we're
gonna do that a lot of good stuff coming
up join patreon if you want to support
the podcast without you we could not do
this show patreon.com inside of you
um Eric McCormick and Stephen Weber guys
that I was big fans of and big fans of
been watching for a long time and
they're not much older than I am maybe
you are Stephen
I don't know how old they are actually
they look so good I don't even know how
old they are and we don't need to get an
age you talk about it you talked about
it I know I know right I talk about age
I like to talk about age people you
can't ask a woman their age like I did
hey I'm my thing is like I'm 50. you got
to be like 34 like I'm 52 I'm like Oh my
God look at that don't worry that's the
way to do it that's you gotta do that
you're 34. well thank you
I don't know I don't know what you could
do they've got a great new podcast not
only are they big stars TV movie stars
they've done so much work but now they
have a new podcast that just is a blast
it's called eating out
I know there's a lot of you purrs out
there just thought something but it's
what it says it is you have to check
this out but listen to this conversation
with them they'll tell you so much more
about it uh they were great guests I'm
delighted to have them in the studio
with me
um they were so nice to my dog I hope
you see some pictures I'll post about
with Eric and the uh and my little puppy
uh Charlie who's older now and still
pissing
I always say my dog likes to potty all
the time potty all the time party all
the time that was Eddie Murphy saying
that you know that was it yeah Eddie
Murphy he had one song and who's that he
also had a song in his album called put
a boogie In Your Butt I put a tree in
your butt I'll stick me in your butt it
just in your butt it's called in your
butt listen to it uh anyway let's get
inside of Eric McCormick and Stephen
Weber
It's My Party
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
she was a show girl with yellow feathers
in her hair and a dream go down to there
she would merengue and do the Cha-Cha
we all ended Uncharted she was the woman
who um
um wall of sound Phil Spector killed
well thanks for bringing the way to
start the podcast off with death why
don't we get into Gordon Lightfoot yeah
well we should he's now uh luckily he's
uh he was booked to play the lounge in
the Edmund Fitzgerald
don't expose me this is uh how am I
gonna get good I like to say that he's
riding that Canadian railroad in the sky
you know what I mean well there was a
time in this Fair land where the real
rule did not run
man have you ever seen a concert yeah
when I was 14
so I'm in Toronto and uh and then some
again only a few years ago maybe five he
was very thin and frail and the baritone
part had gone yeah so yeah yeah I love
that song I love that too I love it you
know what my mom I think my mom banged
him really if she didn't have sex with
him she made out with him wow yeah he
was I mean he was about it in the day it
was in the day pretty good looking guy
but she was married yeah oh that
probably wasn't a good thing but they're
divorced now we spill the beans on this
I mean we do you look at me like this
Stephen I'd feel unsafe here
as you should with all these horror
movies and I'll tell you what no man
this is my whole thing I'm so into this
[__] I I love the thing Escape From
New York you know and also I've been
listening to to my podcasts uh Quentin
Tarantino and Roger Avery's podcast
they've got a great one really uh and
they dissect all these genre heavy films
and B movies and sometimes they'll do an
a film like they just did the hospital
George C Scott but then they'll do uh
you know the the getaway and then
they'll do kind of odd kind of fringy
films too and really kind of break them
down really fun can you do a good uh
George C Scott impression oh God
you can only do one when he yells right
it's not in the files and he does that
you owe me money that's pretty good and
in the movie Rage he says God damn it
like God would [__] his pants
God damn
there's nobody like him in show business
today who has that bottled rage who that
that was like his selling point they
also did he also did uh comedies you
know but I did he did one um oh the the
bond the Kubrick one that was kind of
well no that was uh that was great
that's right that's strange love yeah
also he did one where he played kind of
Sherlock Holmes I think it's called They
Might Be Giants
too yeah the band gets its name you know
the mighty Giants I know I don't know
the music that well but I never knew
where they got their name little little
birdhouse
yeah yeah that's right so I could tell
why your friends and why you have a
podcast it's just like it's just
non-stop are you exhausted as I am after
an interview you just want to take a nap
isn't it funny how exhausting it is
you're like what I just sat here and you
know and there's sort of the the LIE the
hook of the show and the LIE of the show
is that it's not an interview because we
have two people on it and it's a
conversation right still it's up to us
to keep that conversation alive and
going yeah they don't have to they can
just sit there and wait so it is tiring
mentally and vocally I think too but at
the same time everybody knows why we're
there and so everybody's up a little bit
everybody performs a little bit right
but they're chewing and chewing food are
they chewing loud have you had a a real
loud we encourage it we really do we
want that and we want the sound of forks
and nuts
chewing and also we want this
he was shockingly gentle he was a
shockingly gentle really he's a nice guy
he's the greatest he's like so nice
everything's nice
yeah I don't do him you just did that he
was very good really yeah all you have
to do is be a little jewy can I say that
because I'm a Jew I'm a Jew too but he
can't you can't say there no you can I
can say it but why would I why would you
take the risk yeah especially now it's
right eating out eating out with Eric
and Steve I mean who came up with that
one well it makes sense we're eating out
but it could be it's a double entender
like my podcast
what are you talking about Michael first
time you've heard that Eric
um sick [__] the other one that I loved
which was I think eating out was mine I
think but but the other one was it was
it yours yes of course all right
um
but the uh the one that was Stevens that
I really loved was a mutual mastication
that's what I that's the title I thought
I we really should go that would have
got us in Dutch yeah yeah with the Dutch
you were always angry are they yeah why
do they have to be angry about exactly
are you kidding watch what the shoes and
the cheese
but they live in such a beautiful place
oh [__] them and [__] the duck [__] the
dust hey don't say that oh we're kidding
we need we love the Dutch you probably
have at least one percent of the Dutch
you're watching them I love dance
Amsterdam swings had a huge Dutch uh
demo really Wings didn't know of course
not
I mean look you guys have done so much
work I mean I could sit here and go on
about all the things you've done
I won't
unless you want me to what are you gonna
do with it now I mean as well well I
mean it's just like you know you you're
on the new Chicago Med yes right how
many is that what season hey it's like
in its 80th season no actually Chicago
Med I think is this is gonna be going
into its ninth season uh and then it's
part of a Triad with Chicago Fire which
I think is maybe in its 11th season in
Chicago PD which is in its 10th season
how many episodes of Chicago dermatology
Chicago nose and throat what is it NCI
Nebraska yeah yeah it's just endless
yeah but it's like it's probably a good
paycheck right it's really good yeah of
course it's good first of all I'm
grateful at the state of the game for me
to be able to pull a decent paycheck
because well because you have a shelf
life don't you think that actors of a
certain age I'm 62. yes I've got a
swimmers build but you know but and I
still look like I still look good you
both look really so bad I don't know how
old you are I'm 51. I'm struggling I
turned 60 last week what and uh and yeah
here we are and I agree I mean it's just
I really particularly after covet I
thought okay that was I guess I'm
retired I mean what's we're all going to
come back and be vying for the same
number of smaller number of jobs but
it's been a good year old people
knocking over a bank
type of [__] yes I don't know I think
that you guys will always have work you
always find work because you're good at
what you do so there's no reason why you
shouldn't work you could always work the
question is my mentality is like if I
can make enough money not to work that
just sounds great but you act right I
mean so you're yeah but I you know I I
did for so long and I loved it and now
I'm like unless it's something I
absolutely love I kind of like doing the
podcasts and traveling and and just
enjoying you know as much as I can you
just never know when it's gonna happen I
always look at those people that work
till they're like 80 or not Clint
Eastwood's 92 when he was doing another
movie it's like what else why he must
love it he can't need the money right yo
yo he definitely he definitely needs the
money for the for the life that's right
you know for for me it was it was coming
out of the theater it was bread in me it
was like you're supposed to one day play
Lear and if you don't what what are you
in this for I don't want to play Lear at
all but I do want want to kind of still
be in it to some degree I want I don't
do I want to be sitting around in a in a
trailer waiting for my one scene on that
when I'm 78 probably not but also that's
the that's the weird part of the of the
business that people don't know that
that the majority of her time is spent
kind of waiting around it's spent not
being creative or not in doing a scene
with somebody and feeling inspired and
all that stuff it's mostly you know
eating snacks and or trying to avoid
eating snacks and memorizing lines and
now scrolling endlessly Doom scrolling
but you're you're doing going back to
Broadway this summer yeah the cottage
caught by Jason Alexander I love Jason
he was on the podcast yes I love him
he's the nicest guy ever the topic guy
that is so busy and actually loves and
actually busies himself with stuff that
he loves yeah he's attached to several
plays as a director this is actually his
uh rite of passage as a bra Broadway
director so I'm getting to be in the in
the front row for that I can't I can't
wait I've missed we were talking about
this today that we our jobs were in
front of an audience the sitcom world
back then was the audience an audience
that loved your show couldn't wait they
couldn't believe they got tickets
couldn't wait to show up so it was rabid
and fun and every Tuesday night in my
case was uh was Heaven and I miss that
since uh pre-covered since just the
months before I just be in front of a
crowd I started in theater and you know
high school and college and then off off
Broadway like New Jersey Broadway and
there's there's the doorbell here that's
a nice doorbell but uh you know for me I
loved acting and then I got into film
and TV and I stopped doing that live
stuff I I don't know what it is but the
more I stayed away from it the more
nervous I got sure going back are you
nervous yeah I mean I'm yeah I only in I
think it's just
particularly you know between the the
sitcom script changing every week and
then I had a show I did for three years
for TNT where I was I was constantly
memorizing long uh Neuroscience passages
my memory was on fire for years and
years and years and now it's been at
least you know three years of lockdown
and I haven't had to memorize anything
and so I think it's just I muscle it's
muscle memory and just that kind of what
I call the Gremlins those little things
in your ear that go you're gonna [__] up
yeah here you go I know oh I know you
know the library you don't really know
and and it's that's that's the scariest
thing with theater to me is just I can
know it cold and do it for four weeks
and there'll be that one night where if
something says not tonight I mean did
you miss it did you hanker for it I
think I missed it in the beginning and
then like if you were if you were
offered some role or an opportunity to
to step onto a stage and do kind of a
meaty role would you consider it I don't
know I I I don't I don't know it'd have
to be something like I saw a poster of
Glengarry guy
did you direct it no I was uh I was Roma
in it and this was uh this was 2010 in
Vancouver uh you have to be older to do
that right it can't be that's the thing
was all my my Canadian actor Pals all
realized in about 2007 that we were in
our 40s and we were allowed now it
wasn't a class anymore we were
legitimately a great cast of the show
and it really was a terrific production
that you only saw if you were in
Vancouver but it's one of my proudest
achievements I I that's great I've never
seen it live but I love that movie so
much all the actors what what character
did you play I was a Pacino's character
oh my God can you still say that all all
wait wait all terrain compartments smell
uh probably all drink Apartments Bagley
smell of [__] smell vague the uh yeah
here's the Train opening
all terrain compartments smell vaguely
of [__] it gets you know minded that's
the worst thing that I can confess
you remember you do have a good memory
hurry
this episode is brought to you by better
help better help online therapy I talk
about therapy all the time and mental
health and this is what the podcast is
all about and I can't say enough about
better help they've been a great sponsor
and I think it's because it helps people
and it's simple and affordable and uh
you know I know how much therapy can
cost Ryan you've seen like you know
these guys in California or everywhere
it's just like they charge a fortune per
hour and it actually is added stress so
you're going into therapy stress but
better help to me is is just the way to
go
um if you're worried about you know this
the stigma is it's going away people now
I mean if you if people train to get
their muscles
your brain needs uh working out it needs
therapy you need therapy we need therapy
and you can talk about anything you'd be
surprised with little things that you
don't think are big and you talk to them
about a therapist and you're like oh
that's why I do that oh he finds so much
rewarding things about yourself that um
you can turn around you can change you
could work on and you have somebody here
there who's a trained professional and
with everything that's going on around
us it can be hard to focus on our
well-being and many are stretched thin
and burned out from the the candle
burning you know both both ends and
that's that's me and you forget about
you
um
therapy is is important you need caring
compassionate uh people who want to take
care of you and those are found at
betterhelp.com this totally online
source for therapy has helped thousands
find peace of mind and Direction during
these trying times betterhelp.com
understands we all need to develop
better coping skills and ways to set
boundaries to empower us to become the
best version of ourselves let me
recommend betterhelp.com if you're
considering trying therapy it's a quick
questionnaire
and you'll be matched with a licensed
therapist and guess what you can cancel
at any time you can quit a therapist and
say that's not working he or she is not
working or they they're not it's not
working and go to someone else find
someone else that's that's it's a
process sometimes you get lucky boom
first one
um Ryan changed one time I did and now
it's great it's great I've been with
this one for over a year but there you
go from the horse's mouth no offense uh
find more balance with better help visit
betterhelp.com inside today to get 10
off your first month that's betterhelp
h-e-l-p.com slash inside
that's great I love that yeah maybe I'd
love to do that like but it's a
different kind of artistic that's a the
kind of haughty word but a different
kind of artist autistic artistic
commitment it's a different artistic
commitment than the ones that we're
talking about doing films or TV which is
absolutely cool and fun one but you do
those in spurts you know like fits and
starts whereas
the curtain comes up and brother you are
on and you're in it and you're you're
swept along and it's I'm feeling it now
as I'm talking it it's so exciting and
different from you know from doing TV
and film it's a different discipline
obviously there are people who have
unbelievably
Adept at doing you know film and TV and
stuff but holy [__] it's a totally
different discipline and really exciting
could you both right now
could you do Will and Grace could you do
wings with the workload and and all that
could you do it right now
oh yeah because I mean I think this the
dirty secret of sitcom is that it's not
that many hours a week right it's the
writers that work hard it's the people
building the sets
um but for me I I found that because the
reboot just ended a couple of years ago
I mean that is a kind of
um Sprint for me that's a fabulous
Sprint whereas I think doing an
hour-long show out of town away from
your family oh so this seems at night I
mean yeah I mean small and you're in my
favorite town of Vancouver is my
favorite town I love it um it was a
great time it is and uh but it's that
that takes it out of you that is a
different commitment than the sort of
quick party that sitcom can but sitcoms
to me kind of make me a little nervous
because I did them I did a couple of
short-lived ones for two years and two
years and that you know changing lines
on you last minute and throwing stuff at
you it was just like like I it was
always so nerve-wracking that night or
that week that I was just like oh I just
collapsed on a Saturday for me it was
just like oh my I remember they threw
like this little monologue at me and
they go hey and right before we went on
you're gonna do this like yeah and I go
what the f I I can't and I remember I
said my dad was in the audience and I'm
and I I struggle I need to like have let
it sink in and take my time and yeah and
it it was really nerve-wracking but you
didn't feel that way I think that that
you know For Better or Worse that's a
facility that I have that or at least
had that that I I loved that challenge
to me it was like you know when you see
DJs making [__] up on the spot it's a
gift and I loved I loved when they would
throw that at us and as time would buy
particularly when with the reboot of
willing Grace it was less and less of
that it was more like oh God what are
you changing what really
um particularly for the girls they were
like don't give me what are you doing I
just memorized this today I love I love
the chat challenge of hitting the
audience with something that they can
see the writers just wrote that's a
that's a cool did anybody struggle on
either of the shows that you guys have
worked on with like lunch have you dealt
with actors that are just like they yeah
like they just can't do it like you guys
yeah well well like you guys I mean it's
it's just it becomes a practiced thing
and when you're a guest actor as you
know if you walk onto uh you know a
train that's already in motion it can be
daunting unless you're up for the
challenge and most people are but there
I there was some wonderful actors on
wings that had the worst time now PS
even on the show Chicago Med where
you're doing all this kind of uh medical
records crap that should only be read
off a label on Pharmaceuticals not meant
to be spoken loud that is murder you
know and I've adopted all sorts of
Tricks as a result but yeah that happens
people but also like uh you know uh Pat
Hingle remember the actor Pat Hingle he
passed away he played Commissioner
Gordon in uh Tim Burton's Batman oh wow
among other things an award-winning
actor great actor he did
an episode of wings this guy that
started in you know in live TV in the
50s and won obese and and Tony's and all
this stuff and he was absolutely I don't
want to say throne but he was so turned
off by this loud kind of Pumped up genre
you know we had we had a we had a band
in the oil yeah you know and so it was
all about the event it wasn't just about
putting a show together it was about
creating an event for the for the
audience and he was in hell because he
couldn't concentrate he needed he wanted
to go away and concentrate but there was
no quiet place I went to see um I went
to
um
I'm taping of Will and Grace I think
this is the end of your first run
and and I'd been off the air I hadn't
been on wings in years you know and and
we're friends and I went it was like a
[__] it was like Disneyland but even
Gare you know it was it was it was it
was a machine it was loud and the energy
and was was all over the place and
people were pumped out of the skulls and
the actors are ready to go and wow it
was it was huge it was a huge event like
I'm getting I'm getting I'm getting
exhausted I'm getting into an aneurysm
tell you about that it was so much going
on so I mean it's a very unique
uh about season four how Linden came on
it was Barney Miller he came on as my
sugar daddy in one episode and he got
the night the night that the uh the
audience came in
they were about to come in he said you
guys still do this audience thing huh I
said yeah that's what is you guys did he
says no no we did the pilot I threw it
out I said no and we you know we shot
them all with uh with uh an audience
there and it was just it was canned
laughter I said and you preferred that
he said yeah who needs all that nonsense
I was like that's the show to me that
was the fun it's like a circus so you
looked forward to every Friday night
when you recorded yeah truly exciting
exciting you can look and and selfishly
you get all that crazy affirmation oh
yeah you walk out you get you have
constant laughter and people are
applauding you and you just you feel
you're living this dream that you had
when you were a kid yeah yeah did your
parents always both you guys want you I
know that your your parents were like
nightclub singers
yeah that was you my parents were like
uh although my dad did think about
acting in like 1952 but he never pursued
it they were it was a very normal
Suburban Toronto upbringing so they were
always supportive but it wasn't really
till willing Grace they went okay he's
gonna make a living wait a minute it
took them that long to go oh okay now
he's working well because I know I I
always worked but it was guest star
stuff in a lot of theater and you know
he hadn't struck until relatively late
would you say you were 35 years old yeah
I mean I did a series called Lonesome
Dove for two years but it was and I got
paid well for that I met my wife it was
a great time but then that ended and
for all I knew that was it that was my
series work you know because at the time
most people that ever got a series
that's it that could be the kiss of
death uh but luckily nobody saw Lonesome
Dove the spin-off Series so I was uh how
many auditions did you have for that for
for Lonesome Will and Grace was about
six six in front of the studio the
network yeah it started with just the
writers and I I kind of knew after that
first audition that I was their pick but
then it was it was it was weirdly before
Christmas and
um pilot season didn't usually start
till late January early February so it
just felt too early and I kind of backed
away and I don't know it was just it
just it took a long time and then by the
time I had the world it was another
month before Deborah Messing
came in they always wanted her but she
wasn't available and I read with a whole
bunch of women it was a long process had
Max and David done a series before they
had done Boston Common it was called
Boston Common that wasn't the Shatner
one legal yeah Boston Common just I
guess just like school right and it was
Anthony
um I forget his name
um Daniels
that's right I got the D I'm sorry
that's terrible
very squeaky that made me uncomfortable
what about you like how many auditions
have the most auditions you've gone in
on something that you've gotten oh God
first of all it's been a long time since
I've auditioned and that's not a brag no
it's no brag
yeah but now people don't even audition
it's terrible put it on a zoom
virtual now and really stinks we talked
about that only an hour ago at lunch
that I I miss auditioning I really did
it was because you felt like you had
accomplished something even if you
didn't get the part yes you showed up
you saw each other you saw the
competition you went in you had things
overcome because they were eating their
lunch or they were looking at something
else you had to get there you had to
nail kept you active and involved in the
whole process and yeah more importantly
you got to show your personality yeah it
doesn't come through on a zoom that's
right you're probably trying too hard
you're I don't know it's either but when
you go in there and you could be
Charming be yourself and you know and
take Direction well in those rare
occasions when maybe there was something
creative going on and I look I I did I
did a thing called um uh Murder in the
First which was Stephen bochko's last oh
yeah it was that the oh no no no that
was something that was a win was that
Dylan Baker no ah no no no it was a
movie murder in the first but yeah no
that was different
yeah no and this this um
uh uh this was Taye Diggs this was uh
well so a bunch of actors and I went in
and it was at the end of the day and I
was reading for the role that eventually
went to Tay Diggs and I really worked on
it really worked on it and I just know
it didn't it didn't work and bochico was
there you know Legend and he was
terribly kind and there were a couple of
the casting people there
and I I left and I was really down on
myself it was the end of the day I don't
think I've been working that much and I
decided to turn around and knock on the
door no yeah and I was about I was about
six o'clock at night it was winter in
L.A so it was you know the only thing to
indicate that was that it was darker a
little earlier and they looked at me
they want to go home with this they want
to go home and they looked at me and I
and I must have had something in my
voice that said uh please let me let me
try this again please let me try this
again and uh I there was a moment when
bachco kind of looked around the the
question person that that answered the
door
and they said okay
okay and they gave me different sides
for a different character and I read it
and uh I got that role you know that and
it was it was it was um it was wonderful
on a lot of levels not only getting the
job but making that kind of contact with
somebody
who thought it was important enough to
actually have a physical
presence in this project and not just
kind of
do it all virtually off a computer off
just that choice I mean I love that
that's Brave that I I a similar story
that was not that long ago I wasn't
working either this was
15 2015 and it was a new show called
Studio City it was a pilot and uh about
two sort of based on a true story uh
about a drug dealer and his daughter in
the valley in the 80s and uh kind of a
good that's a good idea yeah
um because she's saddled with Dad and
now I I read this pilot I thought this I
I have to be considered for this role
and I called my agents they called me
back and they said they don't see you in
the part and I said of course they don't
see me in the part I have to show them
we had to beg it was John Wells
producing we had to beg John Wells to go
in
and I got I got it wow and they got this
unknown to play my daughter her name is
Florence Pugh
and uh Fox did not pick it up it's a
great freaking pilot I don't have a copy
of it
2015.
this message is sponsored by discover
did you know you could reduce the number
of unwanted calls and emails with online
privacy protection the latest Innovation
from discover discover will help
regularly remove your personal info like
your name and address from 10 popular
people search websites that could sell
your data and they'll do it for free
activate in the Discover app see terms
and learn more at discover.com online
privacy protection
that is you know I have a similar story
where I go you know what let me read one
more time she goes no I think we got it
I think you did a good job I think we're
good and I go yeah yeah
that's it again
I see what you did yeah they were just
like I see what you didn't do there yeah
uh I want to do it again no you won't
you're not going if you will and you
won't you're not going to have you ever
what's the biggest tank in audition you
ever had before I had one where I went
in I started I wasn't prepared and I
thought I could just do it like a real
good cold read and it was somebody who
cast me in a couple of things and I I
looked at him after the second taken I
go
I'm awful and you know it and I know ah
Rosie it's ego no no I'm gonna go home
I'm gonna leave I'm not gonna waste any
more of your time and uh I love you and
I left and I didn't even come back
that's a self-talk I just I just was
like you know it was just you know it's
one of those things I didn't know I
thought I was not right for this there's
no way I'm getting this so I didn't
prepare and then I went and looked like
an [__] have you done anything like
that well I I ugh for me I always I
think I'm always prepared because I'm
too terrified not to but the one that
was just an obvious one I went right
after willing Grace I went into audition
for Band of Brothers I did too I met
with Tom Hanks yeah Tom X is in the room
and I could just see in his eyes when
I'd finished
that there was no room at all for me and
I I filmed my Asian had for Christmas
any feedback and they said Tom thought
there was still a whole lot of will
Truman going on ah and he wasn't wrong I
I took a long time to get that out of my
bones but but yeah I wouldn't have had
no idea in 2008 how to walk in and be
you know a young Soldier because you
were wearing camouflage culottes yeah
but you know what what's funny is I
remember them saying they don't want any
uh known actors they're trying to cast
all on so maybe that like that's what he
was saying I was already in my 40s by
that that's not what he was saying no he
was saying that yeah
did you did you guys ever deal with like
and by the way I mean these com I could
I can understand where the podcast was
doing well it has to do well your
podcast eating out with with Steve
because I mean it's just like this is
the easiest how easy is this I mean
usually it's like sometimes pulling
teeth yeah sometimes you gotta like and
you guys just Bam off each other and
it's it's nice to see that so it's
exciting I'm definitely gonna tune in
hurray yeah what's your question the
question is look get to the question we
know hurry up let's go do you guys ever
in your life obviously but like you know
people I talk about mental health a lot
but dealing with depression anxiety and
this career that we've chosen can
certainly bring you way down have you
been that far down or you're like I'm
done with this I can't do it anymore I
I'm gonna move away I've had those
feelings where I just want to get away
were you ever that low or or thought uh
you know what who am I
um
for me honestly right before that pilot
that I was just describing was with my
lowest and it wasn't oh my God I'm I'm
I'm dead in this business I'll never I
want to get out of it but there was the
fear that perhaps I'd had my run
um for sure because I just finished
another show for TNT and I thought I
think that's it I think I've used up all
of my my good luck and
um and it was yeah I was the lowest I've
been for sure for about a month so it
was just a month though but you didn't
yeah no it wasn't a long long time
luckily but it was certainly
um it was certainly a a major period of
self-doubt I I had a period of several
years where uh things were definitely
had crested for me and uh I had not
given thought to any future and indeed
it put it highlighted the fact that I
hadn't given a lot of thought to a lot
of things that I'd done in my life
either professionally or personally in
the Years leading up to this and and it
became apparent in the kind of jobs that
I was getting the kind of jobs that I
wanted but wasn't getting until several
years after some you know I
after I began feeling this I felt like I
was Bella Lugosi in 1956 like in Mexico
doing a you know Aztec mummy meets blah
blah that's a good one I thought what
the [__] am I doing here what am I
what's happening to me and it began a
kind of a personal Journey without
getting into that of of trying to kind
of take stock and and change my ways and
live with intention and the moment I
started Living with intentions very
vague to say but uh
things started happening to me
professionally which were better which
were I feel like the result of whatever
energy I was putting out but so much my
self-esteem had been tied up in
the affirmation that I received as an
actor as a celebrity and I had not
thought that through how shallow that is
how superficial ultimately that is and
and because when that goes away then my
sense of meaning left with me and I and
and the me that I was left with was UN
underdeveloped and uh and so then became
uh began a kind of a
you know a years-long journey to find
out who the [__] I was and
once I found that out to improve upon it
to fix myself to make myself better not
that I was a bad person by any means but
um
I had forgotten I'd forgotten what it
was that I loved about being an actor
um apart from the attention it gave me
yeah well you know it's funny because uh
I've talked about this a little bit but
you know for me uh I never got the
attention you know I never got the love
the unconditional I I didn't have
anything so for me it was only Applause
it was only your grade it's only you
know the next thing the next thing am I
you know my uh agent or not my agent my
therapist same thing my therapist used
to say uh it's like a colander you know
it's not sustainable it's like it just
goes in and it's gone yeah not like you
know real love not like real something
that you can feel and so it it's really
taken me a long time through therapy and
things just start to realize going back
trying to find out who you are how to
love that little guy that was lost it's
huge and become you know more of an
adult someone who can really so kind of
uh it was more difficult but did you
ever did you guys get the love and all
that stuff with your families
oh yeah I mean my family Stephen's been
looking up at this guy yeah well you
know it's an interesting question I mean
you know yeah no it is because I think
it goes to everything that uh that
actors can be that we we are desperate
for attention sometimes because there
was none at home there was definitely
lots of of Love at home uh for me what
what wasn't necessarily at home was a
sense that
um
I was like I say it was very Suburban
there I didn't grow up in an in a
pulsating fame city you know I had to
find that side of myself and I'd watch
television through my childhood with my
dad who uh whose sense of humor infused
what I what I loved and but I had the
dreams came from in here they they were
my own they weren't they didn't come
from my day-to-day life uh but luckily
my parents were loving enough to support
it wow it's even still thinking about it
well I I'm just trying to I'm trying to
be coaching about it I mean because the
I I definitely got love
but um it's more than just receiving or
being passive or you know in in in
getting that love I had to I hadn't and
it took me decades to learn that I had
to be I had to actively participate in
in my own life I had to have a purpose I
had to Define myself and as a young man
even with
um the good results I was getting as a
young actor making people laugh or
getting jobs or whatever and and making
my friends laugh and and having a
facsimile of of a good life
um there were some underpinnings that
had been neglected in a way and uh if
you want to go back I I'm a huge fan of
therapy and and over the years I really
went back very very
far and found the roots of a lot of
behavior that kind of resurfaced
resurfaced later on and and I found that
I had created kind of a Schism between
the affirmation I was getting as an
actor and kind of my lack of purpose
internally emotionally if you know what
I mean and uh but I was able to in fact
I'm not just saying this you know with
with friends I was just gonna ask that
well yeah well one of the things that
brought us together was
kind of a maybe an unconscious need to
kind of connect you know to connect and
to create a family or a network that
wasn't just fun and games and not just
based on acting but something that was
emotional you know something that had
emotional truth and Clarity and those
are the types of things that I couldn't
really talk about with my father the
type of role model the male role
modeling I needed you know I wasn't
supplied to me I'm not not through any
fault of his own and but uh but I that I
found later on
um so
what am I saying yeah I know yeah
it started I mean he and I knew each
other uh 20 years ago whatever and we'd
see each other occasionally but it
wasn't until we went out one night
and it's a jar I think yeah and I just
and we just started talking about the
deeper feelings because he's hilarious
yeah and I and I would try to compete
and everyone he is
um but when we got past the hilarity to
the fears and all that stuff it was like
this is what I I've always loved and
what's what leads probably you you're
the same way as what leads to a podcast
is I really want to talk to you I
actually would like yes laughs would be
great but what's underneath the
underneath is always interesting to me
it takes and it's a little risky to do
that because you want to be liked and
you want to get from A to B to C and
without having to stop and explain or
delve into certain things I feel like
you're complaining
moaning yeah I I had one moment while
all this kind of transformative [__] was
happening I want to say in the last 10
12 years I was at I think I was at the
super Whole Foods and the cashier
casually asked me how you doing
and I said I'm not so good wow and and
she looked at me and we looked at each
other and I I couldn't believe I said
that but she looked at me not with
dismay or there was a moment of
connection that could have gone on but
we would have held up the rest of the
people she could have even gone all
right
I'm just saying that that it it one of
the things that connected me to Eric and
and to all our friends and now to you
yeah Rosie is is um a willingness to
kind of go past those
I don't say superficial because they're
they're fine but they're facile that
we're very that's right you know go a
little deeper yeah deeper you know look
time is Time's A wasting and uh we're at
a certain time in our lives where
mortality is becoming more and more of
an issue and I wanna I wanna get to the
real you know we've had enough artifice
it's been really fun you can make some
money and friends and on your applause
uh but uh I don't know there's something
there's something deeper that's kind of
beckoning you know it's funny my friend
James name dropped James Gunn who all
the big Marvel movies
um at his wedding he gave this speech
and I'm telling you ever there wasn't a
dry eye in the house but he was so
honest and he said something like for
all these years I had friends and I had
family and I knew intellectually that
they loved me
but I didn't feel it I didn't I knew it
because I was smart enough to know of
course they loved me but there was
something about not feeling it and then
he met his wife and then everything
started to change and he learned how to
start accepting like I am loved I can be
loved I can love myself which I found
like you know
scary and also
kind of uh just good to hear to hear
from someone who you know you look and
he's got it all and
um but it's it's it's tough I feel like
that sometimes I've definitely worked on
that where it's just like you know
you're in the business and everything's
great go to the cons and you're signing
autographs and everybody's happy and
people go and then you go home yeah
that's right and then you got your dogs
yeah well is that Sally Field thing if
you like me you really like me I mean we
all we all get into this business with
this tremendous sort of energy and ego
and and ambition but inside we're all
terrified that no one actually likes us
or thinks we're any good or worthy of
love for sure and and you don't have to
come from some bad home to feel that way
you can be loved but it's the it's the
mistrust uh and I think that's why so
many of us I I've always just loved
being somebody else that's I mean like
acting is that to be I I I'm not going
to be one of those actors ever that sit
around and talk about my process my
process is give me that hat I promise
you I I will be somebody else as soon as
I put it on and and that's it it's it's
play acting to me but that also makes me
distrust myself in the look around go
everybody else seems to be working so
much harder I must suck I must be [__]
that's a gift it really is a gift to
have that to have that excitement and
the confidence to do that and the
passion all those things combined are
just like that's magic that's lightning
in a bottle
but in a weird way also why we're acting
why we're actors
it's not just about the affirmation
they're also occasionally opportunities
when you're given amazing things to say
that speak to your truth the truth that
maybe you've been searching for
knowingly or maybe unknowingly you know
so that if you're it sounds highfalutin
if you're doing Shakespeare and you're
saying something absolutely gorgeous and
pithy it and and if you connect to it
it's incredibly meaningful and it kind
of kicks a there's a moment of growth
that happens in you which you know
actually leads me into the kind of the
the uh wga being on strike you know the
writers how necessary they are to this
process to our creative process as
actors and also as an audience how how
much audiences need pithy thought out
well-constructed dialogue and Concepts
and you know as actors haven't you found
moments of of great emotional Clarity in
a part that you've been that you've been
that you've learned where you're able to
say something to somebody in ways that
you've never been able to say in real
life or have like somebody a character
touch you physically and and and and you
know um um and intellectually and
emotionally in ways that the people
around you in real life have been too
held or too afraid to express there's
something amazingly I don't know uh
basic about it yeah it's you know it's
definitely cathartic for me and I think
as I look back it was more like you know
when I was when I'm acting some of these
parts that are dark and it stems from
all that [__] I have
oh and it comes out and I'm like where
did that come out come from and then I
if I really listen to myself and and I
could I I know exactly where it comes
from I mean you must have had moments
playing with John Glover right that must
have been you know those have been funny
or superficial or whatever but then
there are those moments when I'm sure
you guys looked at each other and
something [__] you know Primal
happened yeah and what what was crazy
with John I know you love yeah as an
actor he uh he sometimes when I had to
go really emotional and just lose my
[__] I get lost and I and after it he
would go
felt good didn't it oh yeah and I just
looked at him and I was like
yeah and it was just a moment just like
he's like almost it was paternal yeah
yeah and I needed that yeah it was weird
it was like I was going through these
emotions but he was also there yeah
knowing I know I know you're hurting a
little bit and you
you're good touch my heart yeah what do
you I mean when you came up with this
show did you guys say let's do a podcast
or was it like Sean Hayes said guys
you'd be great yeah yeah Sean Sean came
to me and said I'm I'm loving doing a
podcast do you want to do one and uh
what a flattering impression of him
that's exactly how we talk
and uh I said you know Stephen Weber and
I would be fun together and it was only
then that we started to talk about how
much how much truth comes out of eating
with your friends sitting in a
restaurant
uh getting completely loaded oh so you
drink a lot no we don't but does anyone
drink yeah occasionally but most of the
time we've been doing our records in the
day so people aren't not showing up
necessarily on a Sunday with but
occasionally because that's a whole
other thing too right I mean it's it's
uh once you're actually having a meal
and drinking some wine yeah then it's
not an interview anymore it's it's a
conversation but did the conversations
ever get lost where you're like you're
going into deep [__] yeah sometimes like
you're like oh my God we're doing this
we're doing a podcast maybe we shouldn't
be let's snap out of it that's it thank
you thank God for an editor yeah yes
right but it's it's often you know
unlike this where this was this has been
great just us talking about our feelings
and stuff it's very often show biz
stories unheard we have our own versions
but I haven't heard Fred Molina tell
this story or Perry Gilpin or whatever
and those like we could go on forever on
those we have to pull back and go okay
we have to stop because they're so great
everyone's got the to me anyway the most
fascinating stories of auditions how it
got started and what did Brian Cranston
say he's awful
uh he's not what he's crazy from Malcolm
in the Middle I mean dull dull dull what
uh he had a great story and I think it
was about titus's show wasn't it it was
about Bosch right I think so or
something earlier than that he's I've
heard him tell it twice now and it was
just about the the how much oh no it
wasn't it was in Aaron Sorkin show
um and it was uh just how much got
written the night before and handed to
him it was an interrogation room scene
and uh and the other I think it was
Titus had four lines in the same oh and
he just had to stay and it was all Brian
and Brian was said he just he had a a
real crisis moment in his career like I
can't this is insane who can do this and
uh of course he's Brian Cranston so he
did about but you know one of the things
that makes Cranston Cranston we were
talking earlier that now he's just got
one name he's Cranston and he'll
probably be an adjective like oh this
has been Cranston and I've got a
Cranston that uh you know that Philip
give me I I need a Phillips screwdriver
I need to Cranston that nut
that that he has retained probably I
don't know if it if it's uh with great
effort but he's retained a grounded
sense of humility that is genuine uh
against against what must be a torrent
of tempting uh you know power power must
come his way and he might he he must
have been tempted or he may have been
tempted to use his great power as this
beloved very well-known very respected
individual he's very grounded in the
show that we did he's uh
why we're so surprised well yeah there's
a reason why we're surprised by it
because I guess we expect people who are
who have that kind of wealth not
Financial wealth but that wealth of Good
Will to go off and kind of use it and
exploit people and use it you know with
the impunity he's actually he listens
and he's thoughtful you know all the
things that that I see him actually
cropping up on my my Instagram crawl or
whatever are so well thought out and
they are the the fruits of somebody
who's
been aware and who's been present in his
own life and is able to glean the uh the
lessons from it that's amazing
have you unlike Eric McCormick uh have
you ever uh you know they always say
never meet your Heroes you're the actors
have has there ever been someone that
you met and you're like I wish I didn't
meet them it just did you ever have that
or who and also who have you gotten Star
Struck like literally like oh my God I
can't I have to like or do you get
Starstruck oh yeah all the time and
particularly with uh musicians uh you
know when I've um I've had opportunities
sometimes to actually ask the the real
sort of B-side fan questions of certain
people uh that that gets me crazy I I I
have to tell this story because it's so
unbelievable I I've um David furnish who
is Elton John's husband we would David
and I went to high school together so
over the years I've known them and I was
there for their wedding uh in 2006 in at
their place in Windsor and we all these
incredible cars pulling up and carriages
and I walked inside
and the first person I saw at the bar
was Elvis Costello who I'd met once
before and he looked at me and he said
oh hi you know George and George Martin
was standing beside him and I just
thought Elvis Costello just introduced
me to George Martin at Elton John's
wedding so this happened and that that's
that's the most I think that's the most
stars that's huge
that's amazing I you know and you said
you I got Starstruck and many of you may
not know who this is but you should the
Guess Who Burton Cummings yeah are you
kidding She's Come Undone
Eric's got a Eric's Eric's buds with
Bert I oh well so Burton Cummings after
the guest who continued to have this
huge career in Canada and a lot of his
except for Stand Tall I don't think
people down here would know his stuff as
much but huge part of my Adolescence in
the late 70s and
um as as Steven and I used to do a lot
of uh of charity events we'd sing
together whenever I got called to Canada
particularly Toronto to do this one
particular charity event it was Gilda
radner's um it was the
um the evening was called it's always
something and it was for for her charity
and every year they'd say do you want to
come and sing a song we're going to this
big evening
and every time I'd say they'd say do you
want to sing uh something and I'd say
every time I'd say sure why don't you
ask Burton Cummings if he'll come and
sing with me and I never I'd never met
him I was just you know I knew he
resided in Toronto and every year they'd
come back and say yeah we reached out
he's not interested and finally uh I was
I was being honored I got a star on
Canada's Walk of Fame and the Hollywood
Walk
citizenship dual walk of fames but I
said okay they said you want to do
anything do you want to do anything on
the night other than your sort of
acceptance speech I said no no except
if Britain Cummings will do a duet with
me and they see they go back to me
eventually and said yeah no he's he
doesn't do Duets that night Howie Mandel
is hosting the show and Nelly Furtado
got a star and all is it and then it was
my turn this speech is given it turns
out Deborah Messing gave this a surprise
sort of video speech and then I thought
they were about to say come and get your
thing and they said we have one more
surprise for you and the curtain went up
and Burton Cummings was on stage at the
piano by himself and he sang the guess
who's sour sweet
for me what and that
did you cry I cried like a son of a
[__] I did not cry uh and my parents my
parents had both just passed away a
couple of years earlier so it's just
like I just wish you could be here
because that was a song I used to sing
in my bedroom and pretend that I'd
written it you know I love that yeah
that's that's how I do love that what
about you Starstruck or any any moments
nope nothing you never get Star Struck
they're all [__] I'm bigger than Olive
I'm bigger than all
I I did meet Obama and and again you
know I'm not getting political no matter
who no matter what you think of this guy
he was like meeting a superhero he was
perfectly kind of quaffed dressed he was
hilarious and I'm even starting to speak
like him that's good well and and and I
love your blank face yeah
I finally I I met him and he looked at
me the way these guys on that this level
do they're they're prepped in advance of
everybody who's gonna be at some meet
and greet and he looked at me with oh hi
what are you working on
and I I he vaguely knew that I was an
actor and he asked the question what are
you working on that was it and I have
pictures of me with him and I look like
a complete Star Struck like I've been
hit in the face with a spring-loaded
boxing glove with confetti and he's
looking super cool and I look like
you know these are the official
photographs oh yeah so that was bad I
remember uh Tarantino was in a bowling
alley and he uh comes up because [__]
looks Luther oh and I go
I love him I listened to his podcast all
the time I gotta listen to it it's
really good him and Roger Avery and also
he's got a a good audiobook called
Cinema speculation where he breaks down
these great uh movies and you want to
watch them I can't believe it's his last
movie he's doing I mean but is he he's I
mean I heard he's going to be doing
television though Ah that's what I heard
wow everybody's doing television
everybody's doing television
I mean I could talk to you guys all day
and you guys could hear them on uh
eating out with Erica you gotta finish
it around no no I wanna this is called
uh [__] talking with Eric McCormick and
Stephen Weber what uh this is rapid fire
uh my patrons they have questions
there's oh okay so patreon.com inside of
you thank you for supporting the show
couldn't do without you I was looking in
the camera
are they here my patrons are behind you
my patrons uh Ashley R how did Eric feel
about the reboot compared to the
original
uh I felt older much much older uh than
in the original uh I love that I was
really grateful for it
great there that's that's the quick
reboot orthopic you're not that old come
on all right he's 78 years old thank you
he's 70. jam and Jenny loves Steve's
performance in The Shining I mean a lot
of people do a lot of people say that's
the best shining uh any fun stories and
did you meet Stephen King while filming
now I know you did a bunch of stuff with
Stephen King like a bunch of audiobooks
so he must have really liked you yes uh
and you still talk to him uh you know I
haven't uh we we have had a few email
exchanges over the years but he's uh
he's on a different planet you know he's
on planet King but he was around a lot
during the filming of The Shining and I
was able to ask him questions because I
was reading the book while doing it and
I even remember if you have two seconds
uh that uh there was a portion of the
book that I I couldn't understand it was
like a little triplet or something like
that and I asked him what it meant and I
thought oh great I've got a living
author downstairs what does this mean
Steve and basically he was like yeah
this line um is about a bottle of wine
this is because I was standing over a
carpet and it had a color that intrigued
me and this I was drunk
and I was like oh thanks Steve I was
hoping for something a little more
profound really deep no he was a great
guy he's fantastic did he Express on The
Shining how UNS dissatisfied is the
right word right thank you uh he was
with the original shining the kubert he
did I mean he was he was philosophical
about it I think he was he was
ultimately disappointed that a filmmaker
like Kubrick
made it kind of boulderized King's work
it was in effect Stanley Kubrick's
version of uh The Shining as opposed to
Stephen King's shining I never read the
book is it way different well it's
fantastic because ultimately as scary uh
and Fantastical as it is you can see
that it's about alcoholism it's about
the dissolution of a family it's about
Redemption it's about all the things
that you don't associate with monsters
or Stephen King and the books and the
stories that I've read of his are almost
all about that even something as epic as
as the the book it
it's yes it's about Pennywise the Clown
and it's terrifying and all this stuff
but it's about so much more so um was it
taxing on you to do that part taxing I
mean
maybe not taxing enough because uh what
I was talking about before I I really
wish I could go back with what I know
now about myself and about what it's
like to be a a flawed human being and
attack those scenes again it wasn't
taxing I was having too much fun I was
too excited to be there you know and
it's actually it's good it's more than
good uh the the king faithful prefer it
to Kubrick's film but the Kubrick film
obviously is a this iconic you both love
The Shining the original shining I love
you yeah that's great it's a great movie
it's not Stephen King's movie best
moment in The Shining in uh the Kubrick
film yeah
oh my god oh look what's terrifying is
when they're he's walking up the stairs
and he's in he's talking to Wendy and
she is
she's not given way she's not given
nearly enough credit I mean she's been
denigrating yeah she is so rung out rung
out and out of her mind with and we've
heard all these stories but it's
fantastic it's fantastic but look but
you know the the my hang up with that
with Jack Nicholson at that point was
that he was playing something that was
almost like amusement park size but
guy's great it happened really fast yeah
yeah what's yours I um
I I just immediately went to uh to the
scene with Lloyd the bartender oh yeah
I'm the kind of guy likes to know who's
buying his drinks Lloyd I don't know why
that line I love what he says it's
momentary Labs muscular chords
my favorite as he knows is when she
comes because Jack Jack someone's in the
hotel they hurt Danny and he goes
you out of your [__] mind yeah yeah
yeah
I love it I'm just gonna bash your
brains
oh okay wait in the Cranston did a
hilarious commercial uh where he they
redid the whole um
uh with with Tracy Ross uh where they
did the whole shining thing it was for
Mountain Dew or something don't you
remember what it you got to look at this
up you got to look at this up I'm Mr
butcher gloop from the Abacus eljo he he
played Jack Nicholson smashing the door
in and Tracey Ellis Ross was um his wife
and then there's a a little
almost subliminal uh image of him as the
twin girls
in blue dresses oh my begging you to
everybody's gonna watch it it's
unbelievably great last one little Lisa
what song always gets you out on the
Dance Floor oh
um yakety sex right that's the one you
should see him go yeah
uh believe it or not because I'm Walking
on Air no uh no it would be uh You Shook
Me All Night Long by AC/DC what yes if
that if those first chords come up I'm
gonna go out and be Elaine from Seinfeld
I I really I I'm absolutely going to be
what song do you find yourself singing a
lot always like whether it's a musical
or song you have a song that you're
always kind of well I'm all over the map
with that
um um let me see what was uh let's see
if it was a musical lately so I'm doing
a musical in Toronto in three weeks and
so I've been singing those songs
non-stop I can't I can't think of
anything else
at the moment but
um um I go to BG's a lot I I go to
um Deep is Your Life
um um
I started a joke which started the whole
world crying
I looked at the sky
running my head
let's just drop the cuff like that well
I don't know I'm totally drunk they're
on a show oh
they do they do an acapella thing where
they do um how deep is your love oh oh
yeah what's up the other day and it's oh
yeah yeah whoa whoa that's the
documentary
yeah is that it was Frank Marshall I
think directed this did he yeah I think
so wow crazy I think so
um yeah love them so it's it's all it's
usually something very falsettery like
that yeah like bread you have a picture
uh make it with you
um
hey
have you ever tried
for the other side
[Applause]
of this how about this I found your
diary of the tree here oh I love that
but you know what my favorite song it
has is the solo uh yellow uh what is it
the uh David Gates uh David Gates um
Goodbye Girl Goodbye Girl yeah oh the
goodbye goodbye girl you know that one
no yeah you know how it goes well I know
I can't think of it begins
um I used to make out with Robin Leopold
to that and uh so you do remember it
well to the bread album oh it's just the
movie you know so the Dreyfus film you
just sit and [__] the top would come
off
how about wildfire wildfire that makes
me [__] cry that song yeah
[Music]
on a pony she named wildfire
on a cold Nebraska night
isn't she was lost
forever this has been a real treat uh
eating out with Eric and Steve you could
find the podcast everywhere it's
streaming everywhere we watch it on
YouTube right it's no there's no visuals
no visuals yet but it was crushed too
that'd be fun wasn't that bad later this
has been all you guys are in success
uh thank you Michael for having us here
great thank you for having me I want to
live here
use all your toys and everything I don't
have planes well I would do that with
your sculpture if you want to go I know
I just got that from a a fan really
that's pretty amazing man oh that looks
like something that's existed for years
I know right 3D maybe it'll come to life
one time that would be very creepy and
and look at you at night there's a
question you can cut this out but I mean
you're a young man you have to be bald
for so many years I know people still
ask did you hate it
um you know for a while I kind of like
it was kind of cool
but I noticed like I was
I don't think women were that much into
me that much but I think they later on
started with the ball a little bit Yeah
but uh Jason Statham kind of yeah he's
sexy he's a good looking guy stubble but
it was seven years and it was 10 months
a year yeah you know it was cold I was
just aware of how young you were yeah
and and just thinking about that's all
that's you've got to be growing hair
everywhere and you got to shave it
constantly I'm grateful but they they
actually in the beginning it took an
hour and a half to two hours of makeup
to like they had to shave it and then
they had put these layers to make so you
can see a hairline different colors so
it was it was like you're also working
with John Glover who I keep invoking
that [__] can grow hair oh my God like
in a week we need a full yeah we need a
Grizzly Adams [__] beard this has
been a real Joy uh I love you both on
that whatever that note is on that note
this is awesome listen to their podcast
eating out with Eric and Steve I mean
look at this this is the best they are
the best they're so funny I love it oh
stay there real quick let me get a
little picture and then we can do a
little selfie when we're done so we have
a little uh are you gonna hold hands no
no three two
one
[Music]
I love those guys I wish them the best
in the podcast hopefully they'll come
back uh they they were just a joy to
watch together that's why I think you
should listen to their podcast watch
their podcast because they just are so
much fun and you're gonna have so much
fun doing that thanks guys thanks for
coming on meant a lot to me that you
came to the house took your valuable
time and came to me came to me I want to
thank everybody for listening subscribe
write a review it helps the podcast
tremendously algorithms all that [__]
the inside of you online store has tons
of stuff go there you're gonna get
Smallville merch and um uh always got
new stuff going on talkville listen to
talk Phil if you have a chance talk Phil
um is the podcast where we explore
Smallville and watch every episode and
you go to the talkfillpodcast.com to get
tons of cool merch there too all right
top tier patrons these are the folks
that just are unbelievable I don't know
what else to say they make the podcast
possible I couldn't do without you I
love you Nancy D Leah k little Lisa you
Kiko Jill e Brian H Nico P Robert B
Jason W Sophie amaraj C Joshua D
Jennifer and Stacy L Jamal F Janelle B
Mike E Eldon suprema 99 more Santiago am
Chad W Ryan Leanne P Maya P Maddie s
Belinda and Dave H Sheila G Brad d Ray H
Tabitha T Tom and Talia M Betsy D Angel
M Rhiannon C Cory K Dev Nixon Michelle a
Jeremy C Brandy D Joey m
Eugene and Leah Corey Heather Al Angela
FML s Caroline R Christine s Eric H sh
Shane R Andrew M Tim L Oracle Amanda R
Jen B Kevin e Stephanie K jorel jam and
J Leanne J Luna R Mike F Stone H Brian L
Aaron R Kendall L meredithai kerosene I
was watching um
Exorcist 3 again
and there's this creepy scene where he's
like
some woman's giving a confession and so
the priest is there and listening he's
like okay just confess your sins God
will forgive you
the first
the first one was the girl at
Candlestick Park father
I cut her throat and wants to bleed
and his eyes go wide like holy and then
she starts to go
[Laughter]
it's creepy dude
anyway Jessica B Kyle F Marisol P
Esteban G Kaylee J Brian a Ashley F
Marion Louise L
is that right Marion Louisiana Romeo B
Veronica Q Frank B gen T Nikki L we love
you thank you from Michael rosenbum here
in the Hollywood Hills of California
I'm Ryan Taz I'm also here brentez a
little wave we love you thank you and
always Ryan
uh be good to yourself be good to
yourself
all right we'll see you later
[Music]